[Music]
Hello, I'm Holland,
Gastón, the Google Cloud engineer, today I
wanted to talk to you about machine learning APIs,
more and more
projects incorporate artificial intelligence and
many times we find barriers when
it comes to having technical resources
at the level of knowledge.  and at the
level of computing capacity to
face this series of projects that is
why from google help the objective is to
democratize artificial intelligence
making it simpler faster and more useful
for all developers and
users trying to reduce these
barriers and that everyone can
access  to this type of capabilities
when we face a type of
machine learning project the first thing
we have to do is evaluate what
project we are facing depending on
the complexity of this project
we will have different approaches the
first if we have the means and
sufficient knowledge and also
we need a very specific model
will be ut  ilize services that give us the
necessary computing capacity but that
leave us the flexibility to generate
our models completely tailored
and training them with proprietary data sets
for this we have the option
of using cloud machine learning
engine that we will see in more detail in
another video  which gives us
total flexibility but helps us to make this
process as simple as possible another
completely opposite option is in those cases
in which we do not have
enough knowledge for
machine learning to
develop our models but
we want to incorporate intelligence
artificial
intelligence are pre-packaged artificial
intelligence solutions, fully managed services that
allow us to incorporate artificial intelligence
without having to develop the
model or have a data set with which to
train it. They are perfect for any
user and for many use cases
since they give us  a very quick solution
fully managed if, however,
we have a problem that is in
the middle we need a custom model
but we are not experts in machine
learning or we want a
very, very fast implementation here a new
type of machine learning service appears
called clear auto e-mail
that  It allows us to develop
trained models with our own data,
but Google is responsible for generating the model,
so we do not have to
be experts in machine learning,
but anyone can access them. We
will also have a specific video
for these services in the layer
where  today we are going to focus on the
whole part of pre-trained apis or
ready to consume these apps these
models are services
fully managed by google that give us
solutions to many cases such
as the translation of texts analysis
of images understanding of the
natural language transcription from audio to text
generation of audios based on text
an  video analysis and also
more specific solutions for a
specific problem such as the
generation of job profiles by search engines,
new service tests continually appear in
this field, so I encourage you to use
the url you see at the end of the  video
consult the complete list often
so that you can see the complete catalog of
services
now we are going to know some of them
in more detail we are going to start with
vision and vision and piai is the service
that allows us to recognize
objects in images but not only that
but it also allows the detection of
faces from logos of places and
text extraction with all this we can
automate a lot of tasks
such as the extraction of text from
documents for the filling of profiles
detection of images that are
inappropriate with the
moderation capacity of  content so that
someone does not have to
continually review what our users
upload to the web  b facilitates us a lot of
tasks
regarding the understanding of
natural language our app and natural language
helps us with the recognition of
entities sentiment analysis all
this supported in multiple languages and with
he ability to give us synta
tic analysis this can help us for
For example, to analyze the
comments that our users are leaving
us on social networks and
automatically detect the sentiment
to give priority in the response to
each other, a
multitude of applications, another app and very
interesting is the speed u text that
allows us to index it  from audio to
text so that we can
later use the
natural language api to also extract
values from these comments. This
pp not only makes this trans
ription to text but also allow
us to improve it with capabilities such
s the possibility of using
suggested words if we
are using a specific jargon
In the application where this functionality is incorporated,
we can give you these clues
so that the transcription is more accurate. It
is also prepared to work
correctly in noisy environments without
having to do
prior cleaning. It also gives us
real-time results to be able to have those
insights in the  moment that are
happening and in a multitude of languages the same
hing that we have seen from the a
dio to text part, we also have an api that
oes the opposite, builds audio
based on the texts and then also if we wa
t to pass them to a unified language we ha
e the option of  use
translation and play to translate all
these texts the laws n piã and has the
ability to automatically translate
the language by detecting the
language itself and benefits from the
continuous updates that the
translation engine comes up with
at the end google has been
working on it for a long time  this type of technology and
using this app and we benefit
from all  two those years of research
lastly I wanted to mention the
video intelligence api video intelligence
gives us these analysis capabilities that
we have seen in the app and vision but
for video allowing us to detect
labels generating these labels
based on the elements that detect the
videos for  do searches obtain which
elements appear the most in
the videos and many more
new features that are
continually being incorporated into this app and
now the important thing is how we can test
all these services is very simple
we can do it from our own
browser we don't even have to access  to the
console we are going to do a test here
as you can see from the public information itself
in our browser we have the
possibility of going to the console to
test it but also if we download
a part appears where we can test this
app and then if
we delete the text here
we write the text that we want to
analyze the feeling for and  For example, it is
a pleasure to talk to you today about
the machine learning APIs,
we can test the app and from the
browser, without even having to authenticate
, it automatically
detects entities and in this case
what interested us was to do
sentiment analysis, we want to see if
the  sentence is positive or not obviously the
sentence is positive I am very happy to
be with you today telling this
in the video gives us a security a
score that the sentence is positive and
also indicates the magnitude of that
feeling we also have other features such
as  it could be to
do the parsing of that
sentence what happens if we want to go
one step further and we don't want to see it
simply as we would through
the console but rather we want to see the api
that we would use to have a clearer idea of
would incorporate it, let's say  to our
own application we can use a foot
explorer to search for the different apis
and have an idea of what would be the
answer that our application would give us
in this case we are going to look for the
natural language understanding api
we select it and here we see the
different methods available to
try we are going to take the sentiment analysis one
and here as you can see it already gives us
a series of suggestions  we are going to select all of the
different fields that we have
available
so that the answer is complete in
this case we are going to analyze a document
we are going to indicate the type that is going to be
a plain text
and we are going to pass it the same content that
we have used in life  previous it is
a pleasure to
talk to you today about the machine learning apis
here we would authorize the call
and we would have an example of what would be the
quest that our app and
natural language analysis would do and the
answer we would get where
the language has detected us and we  has given
this score and neither the intensity of the
tax score as you can see just as we have
tested the language comprehension
natural we can try any other by
going to florette pencil this has been
a small summary of the apis that
we have as a managed service
within google cloud but as I told you
we continually add new services
so I encourage you to visit the link
that appears in the presentation  to
know the details of all of them
thank you very much